welcome back to SportsCenter Jeff Gordon
won at Kansas this weekend but danica
Patrick's performances almost as
impressive she posted a seventh place
finish her best ever in Sprint Cup it
was her second top ten in 57 Cup races
so some good mojo for the 10 car heading
into all-star weekend in Charlotte and
Danica Patrick joins us now
so Danica can you put your finger on
what works so well for you this week in
a Kansas if it was only that easy to
know like what that magic formula is I
think that it shows that it's sitting
there it's just a matter of executing
everything really well it's you know as
a brand new car that the team brought to
the track so I went on I'm went in on
Monday to the shop and thanked everyone
for working really hard and building a
really good car cuz I know that NASCAR
drivers like to thank everyone at the
shop but that's what that means is that
those guys went and built a car that's
really good and makes a really good
downforce downforce and handles really
well so so that was that was really
important obviously Hendrick builds me
great engines and you know Tony my crew
chief made good calls and we just put
the whole weekend together as good
qualifying good race and you know it was
really good to do for for my partners
for GoDaddy if you could see the site to
the right of me right now there's like
200 people at Aspen Dental being really
quiet I'm at an employee appreciation
welcome and they're being so good right
now but it's for the partners that that
work really hard and put a lot into me
that I'm I'm really happy to do it for
them too it is a team after all
absolutely you know people took note
when you pass Jimmie Johnson on a
restart there what was that I mean
anytime you passed the 48 there's
something good going on what was that
like getting past him I had a little
moment after I cleared him when I was
and I pulled away I was like I got to
stop thinking about that I need to look
forward but um I sent him a message
he said he texted me after and said good
job and I said you know I hope you know
with all respect I said my favorite
moment in the race was when I drove
around the outside of you on that
restart and he said that not a problem
and he said he remembers having that
situation with Jeff Gordon and that he
was really honored that I could be that
driver that he could be that driver for
me
was you know just a big moment so yeah I
definitely had to start looking forward
and thinking about just passing the next
car because you know when he's past six
time on the outside you just have a
little moment I want we talked about
moments you grab the pole at the Daytona
500 last year more gratify leading the
field to the green flag and the great
American race or finishing seventh this
weekend honestly it really is this
weekend it's speed ways are a whole
different animal and it's very much a
team effort and I said that after the
pole for the Daytona 500 last year is
that you know I kept my foot down and
that's not hard to do but it is hard to
build a really really good car like that
and that was a Stewart house you know
ten team ten team and a Hendrick engine
thing and I was lucky enough to get to
pilot it but this one has a lot more to
do with me so and it was a whole weekend
and it was not just by myself out there
on the track it was with 42 other people
trying to do the same thing tell me
about your teammate Kevin Harvick cuz I
keep on reading about how he's helped
you with your drip driving he's done
that from the beginning I remember back
in Las Vegas it was probably my third or
fourth NASCAR Nationwide race and he
stuck his hand out the window down the
front straight and I thought he was
flipping me off and I'm like what did I
do to him I'm just trying to stay out of
the way and drive as fast as I can
and then he went down the back straight
and did the same thing and I saw that he
was pointing the finger up high and I
was like oh he wants to follow me up
high and he did that while leading the
race and lapping me so he he's been
helping me from the very start and that
was one of the things I said to start
the year off was that I was really
excited to have Kevin and Kurt and Tony
back in the seat again to be able to you
know help me on on any given weekend and
they're very confident and comfortable
with giving me advice and I'm I'm really
lucky for that hey Danica we stumbled
upon some some video from your crew and
I want to roll this and get an
explanation afterwards
let's roll video first I'm doing patch
and I'm not going to shave my beard
until I get your sprint fan vote no I'm
Danica Patrick I'm not gonna shave these
legs I get your sprint fan vote what in
the Wide World of Sports was that Oh
Gabe and John were the the beard and the
leg guys they're very funny they're on
my pit crew I tell you what that Go
Daddy crew is awesome not only are they
a phenomenal pit crew and they really
are I'm very appreciative for that but
they're also really cool and really
funny and III thank them very much for
being willing to put on a wig and do
that for TV and in all in efforts to get
fan votes for me to get in the all-star
race
I'd rather race my way in but it's a big
honor and I got it last year to be voted
in so so that was really cool and I hope
they had a little fun with it and at the
end of the day they were on Talladega
Boulevard which is basically like Mardi
Gras comes to NASCAR so it was really
the safest place to wear a wig I think
there you go well good luck getting into
all-star weekend whether you race your
way in or whether you're voted in by the
fans they had a compactor coming off a
seventh place finish in Kansas her best
in Sprint Cup thank you Danica thank you